all right stephen miller former senior
advisor and director
director of speech writing to to
president trump joins us next stephen
what do you make of what lara just told
us
it's absolutely heartbreaking
unfortunately it's the predictable
consequence
of specific policy choices that were
made by the biden administration
that our border agents warned them
urgently not to make
one of the biggest and most disastrous
of those policy changes
was the decision to suspend the
reunification
of unaccompanied minors to their
families in their
home countries so last year under
president trump
using the authority known as title 42
unaccompanied minors
were rescued by border agents we
contacted their home countries
we contacted social services where they
came from
working with the state department we got
them back home
safely with their families canceling
that policy
to adopt the pro-trafficking policy
of sending them to their destination in
the united states
has single-handedly created this child
trafficking
crisis that decision is reprehensible
yeah and there's no dna testing either i
can't believe that we would reunite
children with adults that we don't even
know
are really related to this child it's
really it's really remarkable
i want to play another piece of footage
for you here about um
fauci this is fauci um take a look
i mean having me down at the border
that's really not what i do neil you
know what i do
i develop vaccines i develop counter
measures i mean having me at the border
i don't know why
they're saying i should be at the border
any more than someone who has experience
in those types of things this is so
disingenuous nobody said he should go to
the border
the question is why isn't he weighing in
on
the the the virus uh in it coming from
brazil
through the border that we know is more
dangerous and more virulent
yes well i mean the bottom line is is
that you have a perfect storm
on the southern border for a massive
outbreak
one super spreader event after another
so while we're still living under
restrictions
if you come here illegally no rules no
restrictions no vaccines
no mass no nothing it is a public health
nightmare but i really want to drill
down on the moral dimensions of this
because you you talked about this
children are being sent
to illegal alien adults in the united
states
with no sense of whether or not that
child will be safe
in that setting and that guarantee that
guarantee of domestic resettlement
is fueling the largest global trade in
child trafficking
anywhere on planet earth and it's
happening on our border
because of the policy choices that joe
biden made and if i was a republican
member of congress
i would say to joe biden i won't even
debate an infrastructure bill with you
until we address the border crisis full
stop
yeah it's it's it's a very good idea and
it is a very serious problem this is
probably the most evil thing
that has ever happened and it's hard to
believe that our government is being
complicit in this
thank you so much stephen thank you